Nos dicen que: "Un tren que viaja por Japón lleva
90 pasajeros. 52 pasajeros se bajan en Tokio. En
Kobe, se bajan otros 29 pasajeros. No se suben
nuevos pasajeros al tren", y luego nos preguntan
"¿Cuántos pasajeros siguen en el tren?" Pausa
el video y trata de resolverlo antes de trabajar
juntos en esto. Muy bien, hagamos esto juntos. En
primer lugar, podemos pensar en cuántos pasajeros
hay en total y luego, para calcular cuántos
quedan, bueno tenemos que comenzar con el total,
quitar 52 que bajan en Tokio, luego quitar
otros 29 que bajan en Kobe y luego los que
resten son los que todavía siguen en el tren. Y
podemos imaginar esto con un diagrama de caja,
de modo que digamos que la longitud de esta caja,
o la longitud de este rectángulo, representa a los
90 pasajeros iniciales. Entonces son 90 pasajeros,
y luego en Tokio bajan 52, y estoy haciendo esto
para que podamos visualizarlo, para que podamos
pensar en cómo se ve, así que quitaremos 52,
que podría ser algo así: 52 bajan en Tokio; y
luego tenemos otros 29 pasajeros que se bajan
del tren en Kobe, de modo que otros 29 -tal
vez sea algo así-, 29 bajan en Kobe. Entonces,
¿cuántos pasajeros quedan? Bueno, si comienzas
con 90, 52 bajan en Tokio, 29 bajan en Kobe,
entonces esta última parte de la longitud de la
caja serían los que quedan, así que justo aquí
tenemos los que quedan, la longitud de esta parte
roja, porque hemos quitado 52 y 29 de los 90.
Entonces, para resolver esto, primero podríamos
tratar de calcular cuánto es 90 menos 52. Si no lo
has calculado, podrías pausar el video y tratar de
resolverlo. Muy bien, una forma de pensarlo es 90
- 52, esto es lo mismo que 90 - 50 - 2, entonces
podría escribirlo de esta manera: - 50 - 2,
y es posible que identifiques que 90 menos 50 es
igual a 9 decenas menos 5 decenas que es igual a
4 decenas, esto va a ser igual a 40 - 2, y luego
2 menos de 40, bueno eso es igual a 38, esto será
igual a 38. Entonces, si sólo hubiera esa parada,
después de esta primera parada quedarían 38
pasajeros en el tren, 38 equivale a esta cantidad
que tenemos justo aquí. Pero luego sabemos que
otros 29 se bajan en Kobe, así que tenemos que
comenzar con 38 y 29 van a bajar, entonces menos
29. Tal vez podríamos reescribirlo, esto es igual
a 30 + 8, esto es 38, y vamos a restar 20 y 9,
menos 20 y menos 9. No debemos restar 20 y luego
sumar 9, eso no sería 29; restamos 2 decenas y 9
unidades, entonces estamos restando 20 y
9. Primero podríamos ver esto como 30 - 20,
que es igual a 10, y luego vamos a sumar 8
y restar 9. Ahora, ¿cuánto es 10 + 8? 10 + 8
sabemos que es igual a 18, ahora, si le restamos
9 a 18 es posible que sepas que eso es igual a 9.
Otra forma de pensarlo es que si restamos 8 de
18 nos quedaremos con 10, y luego tenemos 1 más
que restar, así que nos quedaremos con 9. De modo
que tendremos 9 pasajeros que siguen en el tren:
comenzamos con 90, bajaron 52, quedaron 38 y
luego bajaron otros 29, y ahora nos quedan 9.